bonjour à tous je me présente mon
oreille française pilotes
je suis le directeur des affaires
publiques de la fondation bitcoin canada
un organisme sans but lucratif dont la
mission est la promotion la protection
et la standardisation de bitcoin il ya
environ deux mois
j'ai quitté ce que je considérais qu'une
carrière très prometteuse ans quand en
tant qu analyste en politiques publiques
afin de concentrer à temps plein sur ce
que je vais faire aujourd'hui avec vous
c'est à dire partager ma passion pour
bitcoin mais avant que je commence à
vous bombardez d'information se fait un
petit tour des salles donc levé la main
ce qu'ils connaissaient bacon avant de
venir ici aujourd'hui qui est presque
tout le monde
le vélo mais ceux qui possèdent des
bitcoins de deux personnes 3 à 4
personnes agressées ses paupières et
levé la main ceux qui sont assez
confiants pour m'expliquer exactement
comme en baie de cannes fonctionne une
personne ok deux personnes m'ont le
réseau ne vous inquiétez vous pas
malheureusement j'aimerais ça vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez sortir de la
salle on comprenons tous mais ça serait
faux parce que même en la première fois
qu'on m'a expliqué comment m contre
fonctionne j'ai absolument rien compris
alors c'est absolument normal d'être
confus lorsqu'on entend parler des
technologies comme la cryptographie les
chaînes de blocs les réseaux de pair et
mining ce sont des concepts théologiques
assez poussée et en fin de compte je
suis même pas encore comment un boeing
747 arrivent à voler mais ça n'empêche
pas qu'on a bien non plus alors ce qui a
vraiment changé ma vie ce qui va
vraiment vite coincé quand j'ai compris
quelle était la raison d'être de
vitrines donc à quoi ça sert
et pourquoi j'en ai besoin et c'est ça
que j'ai communiqué avec vous
aujourd'hui
quand je pense à ce jour je peux pas
m'empêcher de penser à cette station
dernier ford qui a dit c'est une bonne
chose que le peuple ne comprennent pas
le système monétaire le système bancaire
parce que s'il comprenait leur est une
révolution avant demain matin
la raison pour laquelle bitcoin est
souvent qualifiée de révolution c'est
parce que cette technologie nous permet
pour la première fois de concevoir un
système monétaire un système bancaire
complètement indépendant est
complètement différent de ceux dans
lequel on évolue aujourd'hui c'est pas
la faute du contraste kate bitcoin nous
fait remarquer la médiocrité de notre
réalité
par rapport à ce que la technologie peut
offrir donc commençons peu de foot
allons-y qu'est-ce que béthune
premièrement mais de colette un réseau
de transactions électroniques
décentralisée sur internet qui permet à
n'importe quel individu de transférer de
l'argent à n'importe qui dans le monde
le mann en direct et instantané
bitcoin et événements également une
monnaie complètement numérique qui a
utilisé comme moyen des changes et
unités de comptes sur les réseaux
ces deux attributs de bitcoin font en
sorte que ce soit à la fois une
alternative au système bancaire
traditionnel que l'on connaît à travers
les banques les cartes de crédit les
processeurs de paiement comme pétain est
à la fois le système monétaire qui est
apparu au xxème siècle c'est-à-dire les
devises nationales sont créés et
contrôlés par des banques centrales sous
les commandes d'un gouvernement
la plus grande différence en ce système
et bitcoin c'est que ces systèmes sont
complètement centralisée alors qu'elle
bitcoin est complètement décentralisée
aucun gouvernement
aucune banque centrale aucune astuce
institutions financières ou aucun groupe
quel qu'il soit n'a de contrôle ni sur
le réseau ni sur la gestion de la
monnaie avec bitcoin la symétrie de
pouvoir vite qu'on est un réseau de
parrains pelletier network comme
bittorrent que vous avez probablement
déjà utilisé si vous avez téléchargé un
film de paris bep dans ce genre de
réseau tous les utilisateurs sont à la
fois consommateurs et fournisseurs de
ressources avec bitcoin aucune
permission de vonnas mental aucune
information personnelle
aucune des manques documentation et
aucun capital minimum n'est requis ce
qui en fait le système financier le
moins discriminant sur la planète
maicon octroie à ses utilisateurs un
droit de propriété irréversible est
indéniable sur leur argent ainsi que la
capacité de transiger avec d'autres
personnes sans aucune autorisation
externe selon leurs propres termes
ce qu'on appelle communément la liberté
de transactions
c'est beau tout ça mais ça ne s'explique
pas à quoi ça sert donc afin de
comprendre on va faire un petit exercice
de visualisation si vous demande de
réfléchir au concept abstrait qu'elle
amenait clé la première chose qui vous
vient en tête pendant les changes mais
qu'on parle de mener moi je pense à
quelque chose comme ça dépendamment du
pays d'où vous vient on pense toujours
automatiquement aux billets de banque
effectivement on accepte de se faire
payer avec ses bouts de papier parce
qu'avec ces bouts de papier on peut se
procurer les biens et les services que
l'on désire et si les marchands accepte
également ces bouts de papier parce que
eux aussi veulent se procurer les biens
et les services qu'ils désirent
après tout c'est ça le fonctionnement de
la monnaie non toutes ces monnaies ont
les mêmes caractéristiques communes
la seule vraie grande différence c'est
le visage qu'ils incriminent dessus
c'est pour cette raison que ses mollets
sont considérés comme une entité propre
et distingue qu'on appelle les monnaies
fiduciaires
elles sont très différents
des monnaies qui ont utilisé par le
passé par nos ancêtres comme l'or et
l'argent sont également très différentes
de celles qui seront utilisés dans le
futur comme bitcoin à un seul
parallèlement les monnaies fiduciaires
n'ont aucun valeur est aucune valeur
intrinsèque autre que leur utilité en
tant que médium des changes mais
pourtant les douleurs sont clairement
perçu comme étant de la valeur puisqu'on
voit toujours dans les films des bandits
qui sont à venir les banques au péril de
leur vie
alors si c'est le cas d'où vient la
valeur des monnaies fiduciaires a fait
comprendre verra dans les ministères
il est intéressant de penser à
l'étymologie du mot fiduciaire provient
du mot latin fille lucia qui signifie
fois ou confiance la valeur des dollars
provient du fait que nous avons tous
confiance que nous pourrons l'utiliser
pour nous procurer les biens et services
que l'on désire et cette valeur-là fait
en sorte cette confiance l'a fait en
sorte que nous acceptons d'utiliser les
dollars comme et est dépénalisée de tous
les jours ceci rend à la fois le dos
lors utile et désirable mais qui
venaient le premier la confiance du
public ou l'utilité du dollar
ça semble peu une logique circulaire non
et bien si aucun des deux c'est l'état
par dix dans ses lois et réglementations
le gouvernement a rendu obligatoire ou
au mieux fortement recommandable
l'utilisation de leurs monnaies
nationales les plusieurs lois au canada
qui concerne la monnaie mais celle qui
attire le plus l'attention c'est celle
ci la loi sur la monnaie et
particulièrement la critique et 13 1 qui
stipule qu'il est obligatoire au canada
de payer ses impôts en de l'ordre
d'accepter dehors comme paiement pour
des dettes et d'accéder de dollars comme
des paiements pour ses produits et
services
c'est important de comprendre qu'on n'a
pas choisi spontanément ses talents
parce que c'est une forme de manette
supérieur mais bien parce qu'on est
obligé donc la valeur du dollar dépend
uniquement des lois et de rien mais si
vous avez une idée de votre cours
d'économie c'est à dire qu'il manque
quelque chose
parce que oui un objet la valeur s'il
est utile mais il faut également qu'il
soit rare magistraux lendemain tous les
droits de tout le monde était multiplié
par deux dans votre portefeuille
nécessairement il vous faudrait deux
fois plus de dollars pour acheter les
mêmes choses que la veille
donc le pouvoir d'achat d'un dollar à 1
diminué par deux la valeur du dollar et
par deux il faut donc faire confiance à
quelqu'un pour s'assurer que le nombre
de dollars en circulation augmente peu
trop rapidement dans la plupart des pays
ont fait confiance à ce qu'on appelle
une banque centrale les banques
centrales sont habituellement soit des
recoupements des banques privées qui ont
reçu un nouveau gouvernement
soit une institution gouvernementale en
tant que tel au canada c'est la banque
du canada
donc voici ma description qui s'adonnent
lui-même n'aurait pas pu dire mais moi
même nous sommes la banque du canada
nous nous efforçons à préserver la
valeur de la monnaie en maintenant les
façons à un niveau bas et stables
l'inflation
plusieurs personnes pensent que c'est un
phénomène naturel comme les saisons que
c'est inévitable mais l'inflation est
créée lorsque d'être monnaie devient de
moins en moins rare il est monnaie
devient de moins en moins rare au fur et
à mesure que la banque centrale du
canada imprime des billets ou les fait
apparaître de manière numérique à partir
d' absolument rien au canada la valeur
du dollar baisse de manière graduelle
on est assez chanceux donc là on voit
ici en rouge c'est la création de la
banque du canada
donc c'est une baisse qui était très
graduelle dans d'autres pays les gens
sont pas aussi chanceux par exemple
qu'on pense à l'argentine ou zimbabwe
dans ces pays les banques centrales ont
tellement perdu le contrôle sur la
création de leur monnaie que dans
l'espace de quelques semaines
il devait absolument impossible
d'utiliser les monnaies ça prenait 10
millions pour acheter ne serait ce
qu'une douzaine de évidemment je
pourrais vous dire que dans ces pays
c'est une situation extrêmement
chaotique le voisin du sud des états
unis ont également d'appliquer à se
contrôler en termes de création de la
monnaie
donc ici on voit le nombre de dollars en
circulation avec une grosse remontée qui
commence en 2008
mais si si si mauvais que ça d'imprimer
de la monnaie qui sacré la phase de
l'infection
pourquoi est ce que les banques
centrales le fond bien dans la plupart
des pays les banques centrales sont
liées à la politique monétaire de nos
gouvernements
les gouvernements donc demande aux
banques centrales les primes et de
l'argent parce que ceux ci leur permet
facilement de financer leur dette sans
devoir lever des impôts et sans devoir
couper des services là c'est pratique
pour un gouvernement
grâce à ceci les gouvernements peuvent
financer toutes sortes de projets qui ne
pourraient pas autrement par exemple est
principalement des gars qui sont très
coûteuses des plans de relance
économique
et comme on voit que les réclamants sur
ce graphique des plans de sauvetage de
grandes banques principalement aux
tweets qu'on appelle communément et
berloty donc cette monnaie ces monnaies
que les gouvernements dévalue selon leur
bon désir c'est la monnaie avec laquelle
vous avez investi vaud et un essai la
monnaie avec laquelle vous comptez vous
loger et vous nourrir dans un avenir
immédiat
il faut donc avoir confiance que le
gouvernement n'a pas nécessairement sa
réélection immédiate comme intérêt mais
à bien les intérêts à long terme de
chacun citoyens et des générations
futures
au moins ce qui atteint ce qui a trait à
la création de la monnaie c'est assez
problématique lorsqu'on apprend que
seulement 14 % de la population mondiale
accorde une grande confiance à son
gouvernement
comment exister en eau de l'or puisque
la valeur du dollar
si vous l'avez c'est sous votre matelas
ou dans un coffre-fort voici par vaux
s'évaporer comme raison au soleil les
indispensable d'avoir recours à une
décision financière traditionnelle pour
préserver la valeur de son argent que ce
soit une banque par des investissements
les incontournables d'avoir recours à
une scission financière pour pouvoir
posséder et utiliser de l'argent
ces éditions garde toujours contrôler
sur une transaction elles ont toujours
accès à un autre agent elles sont les
dépositaires des informations privées
c'est ça veut dire quelle sélection un
pouvoir absolument démesuré son avis est
la pire là dedans c'est que nous sommes
leurs clients nous les payons pour tous
ces services
plusieurs personnes depuis très
longtemps parce qu'aucune alternative
aujourd'hui il est maintenant possible
de commencer à penser à un plan b et ce
plan b c'est bitcoin le futur de la
monnaie commence en 2008 alors que
satoshi nakamoto public on electronic
arts cage system seller document
conceptuel et technique dans lequel
satoshi nakamoto explique pour la
première fois l'idée et le concept de
bitcoin mais également explique comment
le faire fonctionner donc je pas si vous
savez à peu près 11 % des dollars
américains sont sous forme physique
l'airé ses commandes numériques nous
avons donc déjà d'une manière
complètement le numérique alors que
l'innovation de bitcoin est bien il y
apprend que les monnaies numérique qu'on
appelle le prime du double standing
comme vous savez tous probablement il
est très fin
celle de copier n'importe quel type de
données qu'on trouve sur internet avec
une monnaie numérique ça devient assez
problématique parce que si on peut
couper une monnaie ça disons qu'on peut
a dépensé deux fois que le terme de
beauce fanning ou plusieurs fois et
évidemment personnes utiliseraient une
fois confiance à un faisceau de monnaie
la solution qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
utilise un système qu'on appelle un
réseau client savant c'est à dire que on
va confier l'avalisation la gestion tout
le contrôle de toutes les transactions
dans une certaines monnaies en étant un
être indépendant à une entité
centralisée qui elle va pouvoir garantir
à tout le monde quel argent
effectivement on a été dépensée qu'une
seule fois
les premiers avec ceux ci c'est que tout
le contrôle du système monétaire et
financier repose dans les mains de
quelques personnes qui font c'est
l'égalisation
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui alors
l'innovation de satoshi nakamoto aurait
été de résoudre ce problème avec un
système qui s'appelle un réseau peer to
peer dans un réseau peer to peer comme
je l'expliquais tous les utilisateurs
sont à la fois consommateurs et
producteurs de ressources donc le
système que cette chine nakamoto inventé
c'est que lorsqu'une transaction bitcoin
est effectué elle est publiée sur un
réseau est visible à tout le monde donc
ici on voit en temps réel le réseau donc
ce que vous voyez apparaître ce sont
tous des transactions qui sont en train
de faire confirmer et enregistrés dans
le registre toutes les transactions se
réjouissent de transactions les d'onyx
son intérieur est hébergée de manière
distribuée sur les ordinateurs de tous
les participants au réseau
c'est comme ça qu'on sait à qui
appartenait bitcoin donc tout le monde
c'est un bitcoin à été dépensé à tel
moment
tout dépend si subséquentes est invalide
la grande différence entre bitcoin en
termes de monnaie et des dollars c'est
que les missions des bitcoins est fait
de manière mathématiquement prévisible
qui suit plus ou moins comme vous voyez
en revanche une courbe logarithmique le
nom de bitcoin est mathématiquement
limité à 21 millions
ce qui veut dire que personne ne peut
manipuler le nom de beats coin pour son
intérêt personnel
ceci veut également dire que le pouvoir
d'achat le bitcoin est toujours destiné
à augmenter sur le long terme ce qui
fait en sorte que ce soit une
informatique très attrayante omanais
hyperinflationniste donc le vélo mais
ceux qui ont déjà fait un achat par
carte de crédit
j'imagine presque tout le monde est-ce
que vous avez par combien d'étapes cet
achat est passé
est ce que vous savez entre combien
demain votre argent est passé ça
pourrait vous surprendre
voici les principaux intermédiaires et
les principales d'étape pour
l'autorisation de votre carte de crédit
voici les principaux intermédiaires les
principales étapes pour les
réglementations bon un règlement et la
compensation ce qu'on appelle
communément les paiements ce qui est
important de comprendre ces cas chacune
de ces étapes chacun des intermédiaires
a accès à vos informations peut stopper
la transaction et ces gens ne
travaillent pas pour des pinottes loin
de la transaction bitcoin n'implique que
les partis qui veulent volontairement
transiger n'a besoin de la banalisation
de personne d'autre
la permission de personne d'autre
absolument aucun intermédiaire donc une
transaction 100% direct conceptuellement
c'est vraiment l'équivalent d'une
transaction cash mais à main mais sur
une longue distance
l'autorisation est faite par
l'utilisateur à travers un principe qui
s'appelle la cryptographie asymétrique
un peu trop compliqué pour que
j'explique 6 mai l'autorisation elle est
visible sur la chaîne de blogs la
compensation et le règlement sont
effectués de manière distribuée par tous
les utilisateurs sur le réseau
elle est également confirmé sur la
chaîne de blocs je peux se déprécier
mais la chaîne de blog c'est le nom du
registre qu'on voyait tantôt c'est ça la
chaîne de bloquer un avantage concert de
bitcoin aussi c'est que c'est un outil
fort de protection de la vie privée
l'année dernière aux états unis sept
millions de personnes ont été victimes
de fraude liés au vol d'identité
ces personnes ont perdu collectivement
21 milliards de dollars et quelle était
la source de ces fraudes 90% moitié
moitié
les cartes de crédit et les banques en
effet on est obligé de donner un nombre
que je trouve moi même absurde
d'informations personnelles aux et son
banc caire voici les informations
nécessaires à donner pour faire un
virement bancaire
il y en a 12 on ne le dira pas mais
quand vous ouvrez votre compte en plus
de cela vous devez fournir des pièces
d'identité ainsi qu'une preuve la drees
voici les informations nécessaires est
requise pour une transaction bitcoin la
clé publique de rester bien en terre qui
est l'équivalent d'un numéro de compte
et le montant a envoyé voici la
documentation requise pour cible et de
coin absolument rien si aucune
information publique privée n'a donné
aucune information privée ne sera volé
un autre est vraiment intéressant que
l'écossé qui s'est tellement rapide
c'est vraiment rapide et c'est tellement
rapide que pour moi l'équivalent
conceptuel le plus approprié s'est
téléporté du cash directement dans le
coffre
fort de quelqu'un en plus la vitesse du
véhicule par rapport aux banques
elle est comparable à celle du courriel
par rapport à la poste une transaction
vite qu'on le prend à peu près une
secondes deux secondes avant d'être
envoyé est encore fermée et les
compromis a à peu près dix minutes un
virement bancaire international prend 48
heures de jours ouvrables au minimum et
peut prendre plusieurs semaines
mais de quoi on est une monnaie sans
frontières ibid comme moi je pense que
c'est vraiment l'essence même de la
mondialisation les frontières nationales
la distance physique n'ont absolument
aucune importance dans cette baie de
coin un peu comme avec le courriel
finalement le royaume de bitcoins et
simplement l'internet
en plus de devoir payer des frais
bancaires pour avoir accès à notre
argent et en plus de payer les frais de
la démission de pouvoir d'achat
le système de leurres et les étudiants
de bancaire lui coûte très cher voici le
coût d'un virement bancaire à partir du
canada pour les dix pays qui reçoivent
le plus de virement partir du canada
comme vous voyez c'est très élevée s'est
exprimé en pourcentage de transactions
pour une transaction moyen de 200
dollars ça montre très vite pour ça
ceux-ci particulier en efface pour les
immigrants sont venus travailler au
canada et qui compte renvoyer l'argent
la famille dans leur pays d'origine
puisque bitcoin toutes les tâches sont
faites de façon détruit et qui a eu
aucun intermédiaire s'écoute absolument
ou presque rien en fait utiliser et
faire une transaction avec bacon et 100%
gratuit la seule façon de payer pour ce
bitcoins et si on veut rajouter un frère
volontaires supplémentaires une
transaction afin que cette transaction
soit confirmée plus rapidement les frais
moyens pour un train pour un tel point
telle transaction est de 0,0001 bitcoin
ou actuellement cinq sous un début
avouez des promoteurs comme moi des
bitcoins ainsi de rendre accessibles les
services financiers impliquant long de
personnes actuellement 2.5 milliards
d'êtres humains n'ont aucun accès des
services bancaires et aucun accès à des
services financiers
ceci veut dire qu'ils sont incapables
d'adéquate mans conserver l'argent ni la
faire fructifier ces personnes donc
incapable de sortir du cercle vicieux de
la pauvreté sans accès à un service
bancaire dans les pays en développement
sagan pour cent des adultes n'ont aucun
accès des services bancaires et
financiers
pourquoi voici les cinq raisons
principales pas de succursale physique
trop de documentation requise coûts
élevés de transaction seuil minimum
perdition ou contrôles gouvernementaux
l'avez compris ce sont tous ces
obstacles
qui n'ont absolument qu'il n'existe
simplement pas un système beats coin
mais de queen cédant quelque sorte les
caractéristiques de baseball en tant que
monnaie sans quelques sorties telles que
on aurait choisi son a voulu créer une
monnaie super-héros vraiment la capacité
de se faire téléporter la capacité
d'avoir aucun mail intermédiaire c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais vus mais
beat coin c'est plus une simple monnaie
si l'innovation technologique la plus
significative depuis l'invention
d'internet mais de quoi une communauté
de personnes qui repousse les limites de
l'imaginable
mais de quoi en alternative à un système
qu'on n'a pas choisi bitcoins est un
outil de libération
merci